I saw something sticking out from the
middle of his foot and his big toenail
had grown over and under his foot and
had poked through the skin from the
bottom and sticking up from the middle
of the foot hi I'm Abby hi I'm Terry
today we're going to talk about some
foot doctor horror stories okay my
horror story came in about 1993 I was a
residency director at the time and we
had a patient who had some rather
extensive foot and ankle surgery done we
had placed him in a plaster of Paris
cast which was like the white cast
material nowadays we use fiberglass and
he came in for his first post-op visit
and I looked at his leg and his cast and
it was basically melted and I came over
and I said what happened and he said
well he was feeling pretty good he
didn't use the crutches as much as he
should have and he went swimming in the
ocean the day before this is just a few
days after his surgery so needless to
say we cut away the plaster cast and he
had a rather swollen and red and
infected surgical sites and had to admit
a little hospital and what was supposed
to be something clean neat and simple
became a disaster so one of my horror
stories has to do with this gentleman
who was a police officer who apparently
had gone through a very very very very
horrible divorce and for years he was
not looking into meeting anyone finally
he decided that he wanted to meet
someone that would be special in his
life he loved to walk on the beach
bare feet and take you know strolls with
whomever was his gonna be his
significant other the day I saw this
gentleman he had come in because
apparently his chief complaint was very
sensitive toes and so I wasn't sure
exactly what was going on I didn't know
what had happened I assumed that because
he was a police officer he had just been
in boots all day long he had blisters or
something like that and when I walked
to the door the smell of in that room
was nauseating and when I saw his
feeding because I when I walk into the
room I see my patients feet first all I
saw was this disgustingly red feet that
had pus oozing out of every single toe
and they were all infected and some of
them were even bleeding and I asked him
what happened he very nonchalantly said
I was so embarrassed
about my nails because I had fungus on
my nails and I was so looking forward to
take my new girlfriend out on the beach
and walk bare feet in the sand that one
night I just decided that because I
didn't have time to go see a doctor to
take a whole bottle of tequila drink it
all by myself and decided to go sit in
my tub and use a wire cutter and I
pulled every single toenail without any
other means of anesthetize in my toes
basically he didn't think anything of it
and he pulled all of his nails and
thought just to take a bath and went
ahead the next morning and wrapped every
single toe in toilet paper and put his
boots on and basically went to work by
that afternoon he had a full-blown
cellulitis with infection running up his
toes all the way to the ankle and that's
when he decided to come in basically
what we had to do was put him on several
weeks of antibiotics gave him a note
that he should not be wearing his boots
and he should just do desk work for a
while until the infection is all cleared
up and He healed finally and he ended up
not having beautiful-looking nails but
he ended up taking his stroll on the
beach with his girlfriend without being
embarrassed because he ended up
realizing that having fungal nails is
not that as disgusting as he thought it
was going to well this is not
necessarily a foot related however at a
patient come into the office a number of
years ago the staff brought him from the
reception area into the exam
in room as I'm walking and pick up the
routing paper find out who the patient
is and head towards the door there was
just something that didn't seem right
didn't smell right so I walk through the
door it was quite obvious that the
patient had lost control of their bow
pretty much yeah
control the bowels and it was a rather
large mess gave him as much dignity as
possible in a situation like that he was
an elderly man and it was very thankful
and we got him all put back together
again I did what needed to be done after
he left
unfortunately this room had to be
quarantined for the most part because
the smell didn't go away for several
days no matter what we did so whatever
he ate stayed in the room for a while in
another instance I was told that I have
a couple in a room where the wife had
filled out the paperwork for the husband
stating that he scratches her in bed so
before going into the room I assumed
that because most of our patients
especially the ones that are elderly
come in because they can't reach their
feet because they have very thick
deformed rough flaky nails that she was
basically concerned about the fact that
her husband's nails for too long and
they couldn't get them you know treated
or he couldn't have pedicures whatever
the reason was I just made an assumption
that it had something to do with his
nails being too long he was also
diabetic and that was part of the
information that I was given before
going in so I again assumed that it's
just a simple cutting of the nails and
talking to the patient about having
their nails treated by a professional
and come in on a regular basis however
when I opened the door and I walked into
the room I was just like Terry was
talking about his patient smacked in the
nose with a smell of this infected foot
that you know he came in with and what
was very bizarre was the fact that I saw
something sticking out from the middle
of his foot that looked like a thorn or
you know
for an object when I got closer and I
actually looked at his foot which was
also almost all black because he had
gangrene set in apparently nobody had
cut his nails in years and his big
toenail had grown over and under his
foot and had poked through the skin from
the bottom and sticking up from the
middle of the foot and it was dripping
pus and a little bit of some gooey
greenish kind of a liquid his wife
didn't have any idea what this was all
about she just cared about this the
scratching in bed and when I asked him
if if it hurt he just said no and
because he's diabetic he basically had
no feelings in that foot and she just
asked me if I just could cut the nail
and let them go I unfortunately had to
tell her that this is not something we
could treat that he must probably we'll
have to have his leg amputated which
unfortunately he did we had to take him
to the ER admit him and end up you know
seeing a surgeon who actually amputated
his leg below the knee so the moral of
these stories that we just told you is
that we're hoping none of you no matter
what the problem is how simple you think
it is just don't try to diagnose it and
treat it yourself with home remedies
just come in we promise we will get you
know read of the problem as quickly as
we can so please go see a foot doctor
instead of treating it yourself
[Music]